we have a crisis of critical thinking in  this country take a look at this what is  your view on the FBI and why they  decided to raid the former president's  property I think  I think you know being uh ordered by Rey  yeah it's a mafia ordered by Rey Rey  being the FBI director  who was chosen by Donald Trump  and who Donald Trump expressed unending  confidence in  that's the guy who's running the mafia  hi Ray and after this man our  ex-president for so long they are trying  to find any kind of dirt they can pull  up on him this is insane I never see  this happening in United States buy they  have to go to jail Hunter is the one FBI  has to go and get it yeah Hunter go and  get Hunter now what does Hunter have  that the FBI would need to recover via a  search warrant I'm not aware of anything  whatsoever